RYAN JOHNSON: One of
the most important tests
that we're going to do
is the breaching test.
GIBBS KUGURU: Breaching is
sort of this ambush attack.
They need speed, power, stealth.
RYAN JOHNSON: This is when we're
going to be able to measure
the color of the
great white shark
in its ultimate hunting mode.
NARRATOR: In the middle of
Mossel Bay sits Seal Island.
RYAN JOHNSON: This
island's the epicenter
for great white sharks
in South Africa.
NARRATOR: Every day, hundreds of
fur seals swim for their lives
through a gauntlet
of great whites.
RYAN JOHNSON: The great
white sharks success rate
in hunting Cape fur
seals is almost 50%,
and that's really
high for any predator.
So with these shocks I
got very specific areas
where they want to
hunt and patrol,
and it's usually right
underneath the natural routes
that the seals are exiting
and entering the islands.
NARRATOR: Ryan and
Gibbs are towing
a decoy seal in the hopes of
encouraging sharks to breach.
RYAN JOHNSON: It's about
trying to capture the breaching
shark alongside a
color board and being
able to measure the color
of that breaching shark.
NARRATOR: It's a quiet
morning, but Seal
Island rarely disappoints.
GIBBS KUGURU: Oh,
there's a predation.
Natural predation
right over there.
Oh, it's still going for it.
Oh, [INTERPOSING VOICES]!
Oh.
Isn't this hot?
RYAN JOHNSON: This
is in trouble.
GIBBS KUGURU: Yeah.
He's using the boat for cover.
RYAN JOHNSON: And even
though the shark missed
on that first breach, it
scared that seal so much,
and it's now hiding around
the boat, using it for cover.
NARRATOR: The seal leads the
shark right to the decoy.
MAN: Woo.
GIBBS KUGURU: Oh, yes!
RYAN JOHNSON: Got it.
Got it.
GIBBS KUGURU:
[INAUDIBLE] one there.
NARRATOR: The shark
and the color board
are clearly in frame.
It's the first successful
breach of the experiment.
GIBBS KUGURU: It sends goose
bumps down my spine every time.
I mean, you just can't help
but feel emotional every time
you see it.
NARRATOR: Sharks
are here in numbers.
GIBBS KUGURU: Oh.
RYAN JOHNSON: There we go.
NARRATOR: Stalking
seals all day long.
GIBBS KUGURU: It's
having a go at it.
Woo.
NARRATOR: As the sun sets
after a day of data collection,
the team hopes for
one last breach.
RYAN JOHNSON: Hit that spot.
Hit that spot.
GIBBS KUGURU: Oh, ho.
RYAN JOHNSON: Oh, we've
lost the color board.
We've lost the decoy.
Because it's so dark,
the shark couldn't even
see which way to go.
He's going for it again.
[SOFT MUSIC PLAYING]